hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's arrow flash QA and a lot of
questions about characters coming back
on arrow like katana as well as you know
what's going on with the guns that Cisco
is making for the Rogues so I tried to
add all that stuff I was surprised by
how many you guys were worried about Roy
after the episode of arrow the weird
thing about Colton is is that he has
actually been on on vacation as far as
we know for the last couple of weeks and
they're filming the finale right now at
least the flash I assume they're filming
the finale of arrow to so like we had
episode 17 of arrow this week but it was
only episode 16 of the flash that's
probably gonna continue I don't know if
they're gonna sync up before the finale
Marc Guggenheim made it sound like
they're gonna be off sync for the rest
of the season just careful for spoilers
from the episodes this week if you
haven't seen him yet so I'll start
actually by talking about time travel
because there been a lot of questions
about time travel on flash affecting
stuff on arrow the way you should think
about it is is that unless Barry changes
the past while he's on arrow while he's
in an episode of arrow things on era
won't change I guess we could widen that
a little bit and say as long as it's a
crossover episode with major characters
from both shows if Barry changes the
past it will affect the other show
they'll probably reference it but if
they only do it on the flash with flash
characters then is probably not going to
affect what's happening on arrow or
they'll probably not reference it if you
remember during the episode of the flash
Harrison wells or I'll Barth on whoever
you want to think about him told Barry
not to tell anyone Barry didn't even
tell Caitlin or Cisco that he changed
the past it's like a tree falling in the
woods if Barry changes the past and
doesn't tell anyone about it does anyone
notice the difference obviously the
answer is no I also saw a lot of you
guys asking about the difference between
captain cold and mr. freeze which I
thought was kind of funny there was like
a separate bonus video request for that
so I might do it like a fun bonus video
for that in the future on two questions
though here we go shimian asks is it
possible for Cisco to recall his
conversation with hair send at the end
of episode 15 and if Eddie Thawne is the
second reverse flash will be first be
introduced to a future version of
himself so just going in order no Cisco
probably isn't going to remember episode
15 stuff because the past change in
Cisco wasn't part of that time loop
Barry didn't pull him through time with
himself as for Eddie Thawne I mean
that's still up in the air so there's a
number of possibilities with that
character it's an easy slam dunk for
them to turn
into the hunter zolomon character during
flash rebirth both those characters
reference working with each other
there's been a lot of Rick cos net Tom
Cavanagh pictures from behind the set of
them mugging for camera just being funny
I think once we find out what a Oh bard
Dawn's new plant is or how it develops
over the next two or three episodes
we'll get a better idea of where they're
taking the eddie thawne character just
to be clear I think we'll see eddie
thawne story play out in a more linear
way so he'll learn about his heritage or
his future heritage of his family about
the flash about the Speed Force and then
take the mantle as opposed to like
seeing a future version of him first and
then seeing it how it happened next
question jevon asks do you think that
when they said Lila had a friend named
Rick it was a Rick Flagg at the
beginning of the episode yet like the
person that was supposed to officiate
their wedding I totally think that's
possible Rick Flagg is a big part of the
Suicide Squad he's gonna be a big part
of the Suicide Squad movie so you could
think of it as an easter egg for that
next question tim perry asks do you
think the katana will ever return to the
show and maybe stop masayo or at least
talk some sense into him I would totally
love to see her come and take him down
as much as masayo is Oliver's friend and
you would think that he'd be the one to
take him down it'd be so much more
dramatic if Miss ao's wife or former
wife katana did it we don't know that
they're divorced we just know they're
estranged they haven't been living
together I know it's a bummer to that we
didn't get a flashback in this episode
because we still have no idea why they
split in the first place probably having
something to do with the death of their
son Marc Guggenheim did say that we're
gonna get some more katana the back the
back half of the season and since we
haven't seen her in a little bit I think
she's coming up pretty soon here we go
the next question nope asks WTF do the
Rogues need money if they literally have
a gun that makes anything gold this is
actually a very common question it's
like if they have a gold gun why are
they stealing stuff Captain Cold kind of
explained it when he was talking to
Barry I really like pulling heists I'm
very good at it he loves central and
Keystone City he loves the area it's his
home and he just loves the thrill of the
chase it's not so much about the
acquisition of wealth it's about proving
to other people or to himself that he's
better than everyone that's just captain
cold though the other rogues all have
their own internal motivations hopefully
we'll see that play out in future rogue
episodes heat wave is a good example of
someone that is just off the rails crazy
he seems like he has a little bit of
Joker and I'm like he's an agent
us he just wants to see the world burn
literally wants to see it burn next
question solar asks my main WTF was when
Ray electrocuted the out of Roy and
nobody after the fight seem to give a
I mean Oliver's just straight-up
left in there yeah I know that they seem
kind of funny everyone seemed really
concerned about Roy they're like Oliver
just walked off and left him there I
think the people filming the episode
that day just wanted the scene to end
that way they wanted to see Oliver
walking away from Ray and race standing
there just trying to figure out what was
going on I think the subtext is that
Oliver circle back around and got Roy so
even though we didn't see it on screen I
don't think that he just left Roy
sitting there that's part of the problem
with making television is that sometimes
the way you want to end scenes breaks
continuity a little bit but it looks the
way you want it to look so you do it
anyway so I think that's just what
happened next question Omar asks what is
hive well a simple explanation i'll
probably like a full bonus video just
because there's a whole bunch of hive
stuff especially inside of Teen Titans
stories but they're basically like a big
evil organization on par with Argus
they're like an evil version of Argus
kinda I mentioned it in my arrow video
but I'm really hoping that when Emily
Kinney guest stars on the flash she is
part of hive technically she works at
mercury labs because they've already
established that in the flash universe
but I'm hoping that there's some hive
related stuff just because of the bee
motif next question max G asks did ray
or the actor playing rate Brandon Ralph
have pinkeye in this episode I mean he
did kind of have red eyes no I think
they just wanted to show you that Ray
was a little strung out Oliver had that
comment to felicity he's not thinking
straight they just want to show that Ray
has been overworking himself like he
hasn't been getting a lot of sleep and
that's part of the reason why he doesn't
immediately believe felicity just
because he's a little bit out of his
mind it is totally possible that the
actor actually had pinkeye that day but
but usually they can digitally remove
that stuff so they wouldn't leave his
eyes looking all bloodshot unless they
really wanted them to be bloodshot next
question since Oliver was missing for
five years in every season is more or
less a year you're talking about in the
flashbacks then what does that mean
after season 5 will there even be a
season 6 with just no flashbacks well i
think you know they'll continue to do
flashbacks what they'll pry do is just
compressed time in different ways or to
different degrees Steven
Mel has been very vague on how many more
seasons of arrow he wants to do he
usually says a good many but that can
mean a lot of things minimum i think
five seasons maximum probably seven
seasons because i think he really wants
to develop his film career and he can't
do that while he's filming arrow over
180 days a year so like they get to
season five what they'll probably do is
instead of the flashbacks taking place
over to the course of a year in
flashback they'll probably just compress
that and make it like a half a year the
other really cool option is is that if
they have like a really cool character
they bring on they can do flashbacks for
that character too they don't have to
just do all of her flashbacks next
question though Harry asks may be dead
shop will just get horrific Elise card
on his face resulting in him wearing the
iconic silver mask and maybe come back
in season four that way I don't know
about that you know I still think
there's some weirdness going on with the
movie but it is totally possible they
could be moving it towards the mask one
of the practical reasons that they don't
use masks a lot for actors is that it
obscures their faces like they want you
to be able to see an actor's face so
that's like when they first introduced
Deadshot enero they gave him the
eyepiece instead of the full on face
mask it's also easier for the actor to
move around and actually you know say
his lines and acted scenes with other
actors whenever he's not wearing a
full-on face mask next question Mathias
asks I wonder what will happen with
Felicity in the final scene do you think
that she'd get hurt or something and
team arrow would join forces with Adam
to take down the races or the the fake
arrows you're talking about I definitely
think that he is gonna fire that arrow
and we'll find out what happens in the
beginning of the next episode there's
already been some pictures from the next
episode so I have a pretty good idea of
what's going to happen but some of you
said you don't really like spoilers so
out so I won't say I'll just go on to
say that no one else in that room is
gonna die from an arrow that doesn't
mean that someone won't get hurt as for
Adam teaming up with the arrow I
actually got some more information about
that like just today as I was making
this video so I'll say that's coming
sooner rather than later just just to
preserve like a little bit surprised I
won't say specifically which episode
next question Jared player asks you
should make a video talking about the
new Jesse Eisenberg Lex Luthor so you
tell me they just released the picture
yeah I actually I forgot to put it that
in my arrow video I meant to talk about
it what they've said about the character
is is that he won't have like that false
facade than a lot of
previous lex luthor's had like the relay
comedic spin Jesse Eisenberg's Lex
Luthor is just supposed to be a little
more straightforward like he won't have
any secret agenda he'll be very open
about what he wants to do and how he's
going to do it from a visual perspective
what that means is there's not gonna be
a lot of fake smile so like opposite of
Kevin Spacey's Lex Luthor next question
Charles asks do you think that any arrow
villains will follow rate to the Justice
Society show you're talking about the
spin-off a lot of it depends on what
they want the makeup of that team up
show to be there are flash villains
going we know at least in the pilot
captain cold and heat wave have been
confirmed the way they made the casting
announcement made it sound like those
characters were permanently going to
this bit off so anytime they appeared on
the flash in the future they be guest
stars it sounds a little bit weird but
they're still casting I think they found
most of the actors that they want and
they'll probably make an announcement
about who everyone is and what the name
of the show is I think they're still
waiting on like the last few people to
sign contracts I would expect at the
latest for us to understand what's going
on with the spin-off by comic-con the
private a big announcement at least by
then next question satsuma asks the
reverse-flash at the end is he wells or
another reverse-flash i think there's
two Thon's well yes there are two Thon's
although i think the reverse-flash at
the end of episode 16 of the flash was
Harrison wells remember he vibrates his
voice so that so it sounds a little bit
differently when he's talking to people
I think what we heard is just closer to
what his villain voice is going to be so
whenever we get to like the big battle
between the flash and the reverse-flash
the big final battle he'll be talking
more like that I do think eventually we
will see another reverse flash but I
don't think we've seen him yet at least
you know asterisk in his reverse flash
costume thank you so much everyone for
so many questions these are always a ton
of fun to do just remember next week
episode 17 of the flash episode 18 of
arrow so I think it Doug Jones is
actually guest starring next week on
arrow so there should be a lot of fun
he's gonna be playing a metahuman I
don't really know what his powers are
gonna look like but he's called death
bowl he has the ability to shoot charged
plasma but I don't know which part of
his body comes out maybe his hands will
find out it should be fun I know
everyone that really wants metahumans on
arrow really excited that they're doing
more metahumans and the actor Doug Jones
actually revealed that he's gonna cross
over with the flash I think he's gonna
be an episode 19 of the flash it'll be
like clock King going from arrow to
flash be sure to subscribe to get those
videos I'm probably going to start
posting some daredevil next week to some
more daredevil bonus videos and I'll try
to get that captain cold vs mr. freeze
video out too because Gotham still isn't
back so I have a little extra time on
mondays so while you guys wait for that
stuff you can click here to catch up
with this week's episode of the flash
and click here to catch up with my
daredevil videos that's coming up really
soon it's gonna be a lot of fun thanks
so much for watching now it's all high
five I'll see you guys tomorrow